John Goodman in this movie has got to be
one of the more unsettling characters
I've seen in a really long time it was a
certain kind of creepy
10 Cloverfield Lane so 10 Cloverfield
Lane is a movie that stands on its own
and that is simply that I feel it fair
to warn you this movie isn't exactly the
Cloverfield sequel or spin-off that you
may want it to be believe it might take
place in the same universe as the
original Cloverfield but even then it's
8 years later so really there's nothing
tying in to it at all just know that
going in
that being said pretty solid movie of
tension here movie starts up Mary
Elizabeth Winstead has left her
boyfriend she's driving down the road
and she gets into a car wreck next thing
she knows she wakes up in this bomb
shelter and John Goodman's like yeah I
saved your life because the world is
wrecked it's horrible and there's no one
alive out there John Gallagher jr. is
also in this bomb shelter so it's the
three of them is John Goodman Mary
Elizabeth Winstead John Gallagher jr.
there those are the three people in this
movie and I'm liking that man two three
actors in this movie they are rock solid
they're so good I don't mean any
disrespect to anyone when I say John
Goodman completely steals this movie so
often John Goodman has shown us he's one
of the better actors out there how many
times have you watched a movie and you
walk away going oh my god John Goodman
when you said that that and you're
quoting the Jeung Goodman line from that
movie that probably shouldn't even be
quotable it's like that you can tell
this guy is off man I mean this dude is
just controlling these people in his
bomb shelter he wants to he wants
everyone to conform to his way of doing
[ __ ] don't melt down with things don't
go perfectly that's like I think the
catchphrase on the poster is monsters
come in many forms or something like
that and that's what you know right when
you see John give and you're like you're
off man
I don't want to be here in your little
bomb shelter with you when you have a
movie like this with a character who is
obviously unstable but he's just so
massive in size I mean just when John
Goodman is standing in front of you are
blocking your way in this movie you're
like I feel like that guy could kill me
it really makes you feel powerless as
the viewer you feel like you're in this
bomb shelter with Mary Elizabeth
Winstead it was very effective but what
you have with this movie is a very
claustrophobic tension-filled movie
about this girl who is ultimately she's
been kidnapped and she's staying there
don't know if John Goodman's being
upfront with her it's like did a nuclear
war happen or did it not I guess 10
Cloverfield Lane is this directors first
full-length feature film which hey
coming out swinging here man there are
worse first movies out there even James
Cameron had piranhas - I don't really
know how I feel about the ending in this
movie that's one of the things I feel
like I'm gonna have to marinate on that
but in the end this movie has solid
performances the three mains and the
three actors in the movie period they
carry this entire movie John Goodman
steals the show no disrespect to the
other actors because they did a great
job - great tension and if you go into
this movie not expecting a Cloverfield
sequel or spin-off I really feel like
you can enjoy this movie for what it is
which is a very good time and I will say
10 Cloverfield Lane is worth watching
and worth buying on blu-ray bye guys so
10 Cloverfield Lane have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more